welcome to this video and playing good
job which are from from Italy and what
is this we have Bert opening hmm I was
always thinking that you cannot really
take this hmm maybe I'm wrong
oh it's exactly the same position with I
go Bishop t6 now hmm don't know night of
three it looks it looks like just the
scholars from gambit I thought that
supposed to be different ok I'm not an
expert f4 is the kind of move that you
really don't prepare against at least
that I never did ok yeah maybe just
develop here with rook e8 and make it
down difficult for him to to get
developed III is impossible efore looks
hard to play it's 95 a move here look
strange yeah probably just develop he
cannot play III really i take this yeah
this he can do storm even Bishop befores
and with now intending g5 and 95 m we're
not sure that I'm really threatening
that difficult not so clear how i should
how I should play him this is a somewhat
somewhat annoying pin would like to get
in 90 for some time but the bishop on h4
as always okay this is not not a problem
anymore um so
also this is a move yeah with Knights
not suffice that c4 other isn't this
strong night c4 can only go to e1 and
then this check on f4 maybeee 393 Jack
cannot really do that he 3 must play
must play King be one and how do I make
sure that he cannot get developed now
maybe Bishop here not allowing any power
move and one possible idea can be Queen
d6 before quill be two made this is very
direct but also so very very dangerous
okay so he wants to that's not so easy
to meet actually
hmm take on f 2 mine five ish appears
hanging that's not not very convenient
okay Kelsey for okay you can take he can
take on b5 but I'm not sure that he
wants to open the B file a various
tricky moves even 25 as may be possible
on light b5 I mean okay k here Bishop
takes rook takes v place queen f2 I was
thinking look takes c3 could be could be
an option maybe he can take on f5 then
but that's not a big problem Queen FC
rook 3333 BTW be CSM certainly a very
good compensation okay let's try to keep
the rukon III hindering his development
and rugby adis next okay is there some
direct vin night you for no Queen B for
maybe Queen B form
p3i can take and that's the spin by the
by the bishop is doing he's doing a good
job I mean rated 1700 gym but what can
he do night a for maybe I was thinking c
3 i'll just take a daddy can just take
it because he too was hanging and if
night a four is impossible i don't see
move this also looks III threatened yeah
he assault I thought c3 should should do
the trick Queen takes root b 2 is made
next month
I made a mistake and I remember I
remember to e5 is not really good Bishop
g4 is interesting now okay so but the
two late night resigns yeah I had seen
this idea f 46 as an interesting
alternative to the main moves but this
was the the point now the idea being
that they're still e5 in the right
moment but if white goes efore black has
them interesting additional possibility
to play something like that that's
nothing totally great but it's
interesting aiming at this type of
position where you have lost the temple
with the D porn but have gotten the
bishop out sometimes in a bit like
CARICOM French structure later c5 but
the bishop is on g4 it's a quite ok yeah
in the game we got this and I really
don't know anything about this is the
from of Rome's gambit and I have no idea
how this is plight i think it's it's
mostly played with g3 but i really have
no knowledge the way it it went i think
it should be quite ok for like i have
good pieces right here it gets very
problematic Bishop before also was
strong young this is this is very very
strong who black Bishop b4 us again
again good yeah but i was very tempted
by this ahead overlooked 95 uh-huh the
computer is not approving it says be
five is ok but it wants to play rookie
five and then green e7 with queen before
this gives black and fled win
interesting
yeah this is this is indeed a win that's
a what the heck am i drawing here one
Beatlemania what this this this is fat
the diagonals yeah Queen Queen before is
coming and here check this is of course
a disaster queen is trapped but b5 it
seems to be at least okay not blundering
anything yet here i was expecting this
well this is this is some very good
various moves very dangerous Queenie
seven is what the computer is giving
directly going here looks very strong no
see I am yeah this is just not very
harmonious rook King a one given by the
engine yeah and after this I'm winning a
groupie eight queen bee force is
impossible to defend yeah it's just just
a bit to the set just too bad I mean you
must have somehow improve on this
build-up p.m. to set up the so very it's
very weak lots of weak spots okay thanks
for watching